ضغطه زر قد تعلن فناء العالم في ظل الوضع
الدولي سيناريو الحرب النوويه لم يعد
مستبعدا روسيا احد قطبي العالم النوويين
تعرف هذه الحقيقه جيدا فكان لابد من ملاذ
امن يلجا اليه الرئيس في حال وقوع الكارثه
موقع امريكي كشف عن مخبئ نووي سري للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بعد خطا فادح لشركه
مقاولات روسيه عرضت عن طريق الخطا تفاصيل
موقع بوتين او الملجا النووي الخاص به ضمن
استعراض لانجازاتها التي تعود لعام 2010
المخبا يعرف باسم مخبا يوم القيامه وانشئ
تحسبا لاي حرب نوويه يوجد تحت هذا القصر
الفاخر ويتكون من نفقين منفصلين يمكن
الوصول اليهما عبر مصعد كهربائي يهبط
لخمسين مترا تحت سطح الارض
النفقان مغلقان بالاسمنت السميك ومزودان
بكل ما يلزم للعيش على قيد الحياه لاسابيع
بني هذا المخبا تحت هذا القصر طل على
البحر الاسود ويحيط به نحو 17 الف هكتار
من الغابات ويحضر الطيران فوقه
المهندسون الذين صمموا قصر فلاديمير بوتين
فكروا في كل شيء المجمع الذي تبلغ تكلفته
مليار دولار اعتمتع بكل انواع الرفاهيه
فيه كنيسه خاصه وقبو للنبيت كما يحتوي على
حلبه للتزلج على الجليد
ليس بوتين فحسب من يستعد لتلك اللحظه
الرئيس الامريكي ايضا لديه مخبا مجهز ليوم
القيامه النووي اسفل البيت الابيض كما ان
الغريم التقليدي الحالي للرئيس الروسي
رئيس اوكرانيا
هو الاخر لديه ملجا يقيهم اللهيب واشعاع
القنابل النوويه
اول شهرين من بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
في اوكرانيا مختبئين في ملجا سري تحت
الارض الملجا معتم ويحرسه عدد كبير من
المسلحين
لكن ماذا عن الاشخاص العاديين اين سيلجاون
في حال اندلاع حرب نوويه ان لم تكن
الحكومه مهيئه لهذا النوع من التهديد فبعض
الشركات لديها الحل تبني للعميل ملجا
نوويا تحت الارض مجهزا بالكامل يتسع ل 25
شخصا والتكلفه تتراوح بين خمسين ومائه
وخمسين الف دولار اما من لا يستطيع تامين
مبلغ كهذا
فربما لن يحول بينه وبين دمار القنبله
النوويه سوى القدر